the hell are you supposed to be i'm
vengeance
[Music]
things will never be the same
dc fandom join us live october 16 2021
streaming free on dcfandom.com
register now on dcfandom.com and be the
first to get news merch and more
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new batman dc fandom trailer they
just released a bunch of trailer for
trailers so i'll explain what's going on
there's also been a lot of test
screenings for the batman movie so some
really cool details have gotten out so
i'll break that down too if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos of course i'll be
doing videos for all this stuff this is
just a taste of what's coming the batman
movie is just the biggest thing that
they're going to be hyping up at this
upcoming dc fandom event in october
which seems familiar it was kind of the
pa still resistance of the original dc
fandom back in 2020. like i said they
have been screening cuts of the batman
movie recently for test audiences and
it's been all good news people are
calling it more of a horror movie if
you've been looking for a darker batman
movie they say paul danos riddler is
genuinely terrifying and there's
supposed to be this big shocking twist
at the end of the movie which may sound
familiar it seems like there's a twist
at the end of all batman movies if
you've been a long time fan of batman
movies the comics the animated series
the other tv shows post all your
theories about what you think that
shocking twist is going to be keep in
mind though test audiences that are
reporting these things are groups of
people who are not supposed to be batman
experts they're just supposed to be like
regular people off the street so a
shocking twist to them might not seem so
shocking if you've been reading batman
your whole life but the general vibe of
the movie is that robert pattinson's
batman is only in his second year year
two batman and he hasn't uncovered all
the criminality of gotham city yet he's
just been going after the surface level
criminals and just based on the last big
batman trailer the riddler despite being
a classic batman villain is trying to
expose all this corruption in gotham
city like he kills the mayor that's who
this body is supposed to be but at the
crime scene he lays all this evidence
all over the place exposing the mayor's
lies he calls out batman during the
trailer his voiceover demanding that if
he truly seeks justice he'll stop
turning a blind eye to what the riddler
thinks are the real criminals in gotham
and it's been a long time trope of
batman stories movies tv shows that the
politicians the judges the court system
even the police are just as bad as the
regular batman villains like the joker
the riddler two-face i say catwoman but
she's not a batman villain in the way
you normally think of batman villains
she is a true neutral character
alignment so sometimes she works with
the villain sometimes she works with
batman we'll probably see both of those
during the movie just like in batman
returns with that version of catwoman
zoe kravitz is playing the selena kyle
version of catwoman during the matt
reeves batman universe and apparently
test audiences love all the catwoman
stuff so it sounds like zoey kravitz is
gonna kill it as the new selena kyle the
villains are often you know some of the
most if not the most exciting part of
the movies i mean the rogues gallery is
incredible and what i wanted to do
was i wanted to see a batman that was
not an origin tale but was sort of in
these early days but that meant that a
lot of the characters who are the rogues
gallery characters are in their origins
in a way and so we have a selena kyle
who's not yet catwoman selena can take
care of herself she's incredibly tough
she really wants to fight for those who
don't have someone else to fight for
them and i think that is where batman
and she really connect
what's most interesting about celina
kyle is that she represents the savior
for the ill-treated the forgotten the
people that have not had anybody looking
after them she's also very complicated
you don't quite know exactly where her
loyalty or her legions lie
they also reported there's a lot of good
alfred scenes with andy circus's version
of the character he seems like a much
more intense version of alfred even
though jeremy irons alfred was pretty
intense they also confirmed that they're
going to be showing off a new flash
movie trailer and you may remember there
was a big featurette for the movie that
leaked a while ago warner brothers took
it down super quick which is why i
didn't make a video about it but during
that trailer they showed you ezra
miller's flash inside michael keaton's
bat cave with his batman it looks like a
much larger version of his batcave from
the tim burton batman movies mostly
because it's just easier for them to do
a more spectacular version with modern
special effects they also depicted
scenes of a big team-up fight with
michael keaton's batman in a version of
his classic batman suit from the tim
burton movies it seems very familiar to
the original suits he's flying in a
version of his bat jet while supergirl
and the flash are on a building seeming
like they're in the middle of a fight
scene and there were a couple other
scenes of ezra miller's flash inside
michael keaton's batmobile with batman
driving around and did all the previews
i got a lot of questions about this they
kept blurring someone's body out like
there's a third person standing with
them and sometimes in the background
that they kept blurring out like an
extra person in the background here that
they don't want you to see because of
spoilers and based on all the recent
rumors and scenes from the movie that
got out separately i think that blurred
person is supposed to be the secret main
villain of the movie and right now the
rumor is that instead of reverse flash
because this is a flashpoint inspired
story instead of him they're actually
going with a dark flash like evil barry
from another universe as the villain of
the film and during all these shots with
blurry man here in the background it's
actually barry riding around with evil
barry in batman also in the larger fight
scene when they're all teaming up
together like it's them fighting evil
berry and that's why he's blurred out
because they don't want you to see that
he looks just like the flash if you
watched any of the flash season 3
episodes they kind of already did a
version of this also as part of their
version of the flashpoint story but in
their version of events evil berry was
pretending to be savitar completely
different flash villain and he was a
time remnant version of barry from the
future who was supposed to die but
didn't i just got done doing a bunch of
videos about loki which kind of got into
this whole idea but they called those
types of characters on loki variants
like a nexus event happens when a
character does something they weren't
originally supposed to do and then it
creates a branch timeline that turns
into an alternate reality and that
person becomes a holy alternate universe
version of themselves that was kind of
what happened with evil berry on the tv
show during the flash movie it seems
like evil berry is just an alternate
universe version of barry to begin with
and i don't know if he's meant to be the
original flash of michael keaton
batman's earth but we'll probably get
more clues about that when they release
the official trailer ben affleck's
batman is also featured prominently in
the movie i just did a big preview video
for all the scenes of him that posted a
while ago so i'll link that video below
in the description he's writing a
version of his bat pod that's inspired
by some zack snyder concept art from the
justice league snyder cut zack snyder
had a version of a jet powered
motorcycle that ben affleck's batman
would have used in the movie but it
didn't make it in i think it was just
like too many other ideas that he had
and got too expensive but the difference
was that it would have been like a small
personal jet craft that he flew around
instead of driving around on wheels so
obviously this one is a little bit
different but it's andy muschietti's
version of a zack snyder concept during
the flash movie all they've said so far
is that ben affleck's batman is supposed
to give the flash his new multiverse
flash suit upgrade beyond that you can
theorycraft about them doing a new
version of the letter scene from the end
of the flashpoint story but because they
don't have his father thomas wayne in
the movie at least as far as we know i'm
sure jeffrey dean morgan is just waiting
for that flashpoint batman call early
theory they might wind up doing a
version of the letter scene but just
have the letter come from older michael
keaton batman speaking to a younger ben
affleck batman giving him sage life
advice but if it wasn't clear they're
not using the flashpoint storyline to
retcon out ben affleck's batman he'll
still continue to be the main batman of
this prime earth of the justice league
universe next big thing they also
announced that they'll be showing off
some peacemaker previews that's the
suicide squad spin-off tv show with john
cena's peacemaker character i've already
done a big suicide squad movie post
credit scene video so i'll link that
below in the description that's
basically a teaser for the peacemaker
series i heard he was sort of a hero
down in corto maltese was that what you
heard because not quite what do you guys
want him for
just to save the [ __ ] world that's
all
they released a new poster this morning
too it's him in his car which if you're
not a big muscle car junkie this is an
old mercury comet and i love that the
license plate reads as if it says piss
maker which feels very apropos for his
character the bumper sticker is just a
reminder about the dc fandom panel that
they're doing in october he has the
washington plates because that's where
he lives there was a preview of him
earlier standing outside his mobile home
where he actually lives when they were
filming the episodes like this is his
house that he lives in and as you can
see from his house from the stripes that
are painted on the car the paint job his
costume's color scheme everything he has
is painted with the colors or painted to
look like the american flag because he
has such a hard on for justice and lady
liberty in peace he loves peace so much
he doesn't care how many people he has
to kill to get it thus the peace sign
he's making with his hand out the window
here and also this is kind of funny
james gunn was laughing about this
hidden maybe not so hidden detail that
not many people were calling out when
they first released this poster earlier
this morning zoom and enhance on this
rear car window there's a bald eagle
sitting in the back seat of his car he
has a pet bald eagle which if you didn't
know is the national bird of the united
states so of course he would have a bald
eagle as a pet i believe they were
endangered species for a while so he
might be breaking the law a little to
actually have one as a pet i think it
might be illegal to have one as a pet
i'm sure amanda waller is just looking
the other way as part of his deal
working for her on a continuing basis
the peacemaker series will be 8 episodes
on hbo max starting in january they
haven't given the official release date
yet though but it'll be sometime in
january and it'll basically be him going
on more missions for amanda waller james
gunn says that the series gets into way
more sci-fi stuff than you're expecting
and the peacemaker episodes will cross
over with other future dc movies that
they haven't announced yet like it'll
set up future dc movies but they haven't
said which ones i will be doing videos
for all the episodes just like i do for
the marvel disney plus series and as you
can see this is basically dc doing their
version of the marvel disney plus series
they're doing the big green lantern hbo
series they're even doing a batman hbo
series spin-off from robert pattinson's
batman movies matt reeves is doing it
himself the only other really big thing
that they're releasing at dc fandom is
supposed to be the black adam teaser
trailer like actual footage from the
movie they released a preview teaser
last year but it was more of a concept
art trailer for hype with voice over
narration my next big video will be my
full marvel what if episode 4 video
that's all about dark doctor strange we
just got done watching the spiderman no
way home trailer and doctor strange
seemed kind of weird during that so very
timely they're releasing a dark doctor
strange episode of what if that video
will post wednesday morning just like
normal make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss it
everyone click here for my full
spiderman no way home trailer video in
easter eggs and click here for that
brand new black panther 2 wakanda
forever first look video thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]